Hi!
After a year and a half
From writing, rewriting, refining and polishing
I wrote a book.
Name of the book "I have a lot to tell you - Letters to my little sister"
It is a collection of articles on life, love, creativity, work,
It is lessons and ethics I would like to give my sister if she is still alive
It's on sale today if you want it, and I'll put the link down
But unfortunately because I came out of the movie Miss 2059 season 2
I have no time but to sign a single book on Friday June 16th at 19:30
In the last library in downtown Los Angeles
I will read excerpts from the book and of course I will end up with some poetry
And to 'meet and greet' and then sign the book
I hope you like it
I have worked hard on it,
I'm very nervous about it, but I hope you enjoy it
Good-bye!